hey Startalk fans neil degrasse tyson
here i just wanted to give you a quick
update on the episode you're about to
watch I sat down with dr. Irwin redlener
who's director of the National Center
for disaster preparedness that was two
weeks ago on March 3rd and since then
the progress of the corona virus has
continued at a pace that none of us
predicted in fact the World Health
Organization declared it a pandemic and
many cities are encouraging social
distancing either by suggestions or by
actual policy and so we recommend
everyone follow local authorities local
medical authorities on this we want this
program to help you make the best
decisions you can when tracking the
progress of this disease and fraud I
know two weeks from now I might have to
give a preamble to this preamble because
of how much things may have changed
relative to today so we offer this show
in the interest of your enlightenment
your health and your wisdom hey youtube
a verse a cosmic queries coming up now
disaster preparedness what you need to
know this is Startalk a cosmic queries
special edition focusing on disaster
preparedness got with me Chuck nice yeah
always
always doing this in front of some
befuddled guests yes it's like why are
these two reaching in front of me to
bump hands from Vance I've got dr. Irwin
redlener who is the director of the
National Center for disaster
preparedness schools at Columbia
University he's a medical doctor by
training and he cut his teeth with what
the kids do what do you do with his
health fun children have fun exactly
with Paul Simon that we started these
mobile units that took care of Paul
Simon the performer Paul Simon the
singer-songwriter and we started in 1987
you can take
care of homeless kids in New York now
expanded across the country with Lao 53
mobile medical pediatric whoa and what a
legacy yeah that keep going sure right
right right I look forward to the day
when it's no longer necessary I've been
looking forward for that to them for 33
years and so disaster preparedness who
would have thought that that's even a
thing isn't it just you know get your
go-bag that oh that's the individual
thing there's things that you can do you
look online you go to the FEMA or the
Red Cross website they'll tell you all
that what we receive man has been agents
agency but what will the much more
important thing is society ready is our
government ready is the country ready
for our institutions our institutions
ready is the is their readiness on the
level of real serious preparedness and
pre thought about what we actually need
to do to manage things like an like a
pandemic hmm you know that's kind of we
don't you just just raid all the shelves
of the grocery store they obviously
right only if you look like you're in a
panic but that's right yes yes by all
the you just buy up all the mass that
you can the rest and the pure and around
I'm looking around here see if you got
your stuff I don't see anything but
nobody I think really the big thing is
what does the country need to do what
kind of responsible leadership do we
need to have in order to do it and
should the country feel anywhere near
comfortable right now for example when
we're dealing with this coronavirus or
getting ready for any other kind of
major disaster a huge you know a coastal
storm like we saw the Katrina or
hurricane Marie and so on so there's
lots of work asteroid
that's right can't leave up asteroid you
know we actually give them some love too
we could actually leave that out should
we be worried about that that's another
conversation okay and the answer is yes
I can guarantee you that if the
dinosaurs had a space program they would
have knocked that asteroid out of the
way right so can I just for a second
just for played every man here and ask
you number one what is covet 19 what is
a coronavirus as a category as a
category right it is it is a category
viruses much like we had with SARS and
something called mares mares and
acronyms right those are well it's a
Middle Eastern respiratory syndrome is
mares and the stars is severe acute
respiratory syndrome okay so yes so
they're all acronyms kovat also is what
Cove it is is is a corona virus disease
corona virus disease co19 squawk Ovid 19
of the 19 just refers to last year when
it was first recognized I was worried
there were 18 others walking around
right so it's a category of virus right
and how does it differ because you know
people here coronavirus what you're
getting like what is the deal so the
thing about a virus like this which
makes it ultimately into a pandemic
which is what we're dealing with now is
that it's first of all it's a brand new
virus okay that we've not seen before it
is a virus that has jumped from animals
some animal source to humans but more
importantly it is now able to be jumped
it involves a thought well it if
somebody caught it initially from an
animal plenty of viruses dangerous ones
that animals have that do not only don't
wait Adam in beings correct so this one
has already made that leap and it's now
obviously infecting people but the big
important point about this it actually
can be now transmitted from a person to
another person
and and secondly it could be lethal so
it's a new virus it's lethal
it's transmissible among
person-to-person from person to person
and it's spread across international
boundaries okay all those that we have
is airplanes right exactly right you
know it's not like well let's walk to
the nearest town you know it's like we
have a level of mobility without
precedent in this yeah so there's two
very interesting things to note one is
there was a there was a massive avian
flu called the Spanish flu in 1918
mm-hmm and as you will call very limited
air travel then like nothing and and at
that point we also had very little in
the way of medical care right now we
have much better medical Carole even
though we don't have a specific
treatment for the kovat virus but we
have enormous amount of international
travel by air so the ability to transmit
across international boundaries is very
very significant so if you really
diabolical you say viruses invented
humans to be smart enough to invent
airplanes never gets the security of the
right and asthma and by the way people
there you have it so if you want to know
your place in the universe you're
nothing more than an uber for a virus oh
wow okay so so in 1918 of course there
was the end of the First World War and
there's huge troop movement exactly
exactly
ships so that would be the right the
vector that means that yeah right so
they brought a lot of virus in fact they
went home to wherever they're going
including the rest of Europe and and
back to the US and that was probably a
major factor here and we lost about
seven almost 700,000 Americans to the
Spanish flu but between 50 and 700,000
yeah we only lost blood only lost like
50 or 60,000 in the war all of Vietnam
and all right 50,000 in Vietnam and
700,000 Americans in a night and the
population then of course was yes
now if is this true that the reason why
that happened is because
the government did not want to notice
now does it Spanish Flu yeah the
government did not want to acknowledge
the transmission of the flu here in
America and that that it was happening
on military bases our problem is is that
true no I
you know it was impossible to ignore
there were two my had two great
grandparents who were died who died from
those you couldn't ignore there's people
dying constantly although they didn't
know much about the virus behavior I was
transmitted there was a lot and they
certainly had nothing to treat it with
and there were no vaccines that's so it
was happening it was bad they knew was
being transmitted one way or another
when they're trying to do what they
could but it wasn't much and that was my
era yeah what so so now with kovat young
teen it had it can travel so alright so
wouldn't that be true for any virus
right what would again what
distinguishes what over time from any
other virus they want accomplish the
same goal right so what for one thing it
slits lethal mm-hmm the second thing is
we don't know enough about these rather
than a handful it can be lead of course
yeah in fact the lethality rate is a big
controversy right now because we don't
know the denominator always a problem
we're trying to figure out the
percentage of something so right now the
the World Health Organization as of this
morning was saying it's a it's got a 3.4
percent clear the denominator is the
total number of people infected in any
given moment exactly right and then you
know who dies cuz they're dead yeah but
you don't know everybody who has the
disease we know a fraction and we don't
know we don't even know whether it's a
big fraction or small fraction whatever
it is but so given the number of people
that we know have the disease worldwide
which is around a hundred thousand at
the moment and the fatality rate what we
know about that so you make that just a
division and you find out that we have a
three point four percent fatality right
now which also means by the way and by
but it's probably way less than 1
percent but even if it was three percent
that means that 97 percent of people who
get this virus will survive it and so
this is not a you know you don't it's
not a death sentence you get it's not
the zombie virus it's not the zombie
virus nothing cool no notice he didn't
say there is no zombie would I say that
you say no you're supposed to deny
I thought you knew there was a zombie of
all people you would know that but I put
an alley not gonna pick up more on this
when we come back to us a special
edition of stark talk cosmic queries
disaster preparedness viruses
we're back Startalk cosmic queries
disaster preparedness there's one person
in the universe
who's that's in his job title dr. Irwin
redlener director of the National Center
for disaster preparedness put that on
your business card yeah get out you away
right there either that are always
calling and asking you to help get them
prepared did you know that yeah that's
got to be annoying so you know in any
given moment the seasonal flu yeah no
one is taking these kinds of precautions
kovin nineteen precautions to not get
the seasonal flu why well forty five
percent only of people actually get the
flu shot every year which is kind of
crazy since we have between 35,000 and
50,000 deaths every single year from the
seasonal flu that's that's 100 a day I
will never understand it okay that's a
hundred a day okay all right yeah so why
isn't all of this outcry that we are now
getting with covert 19 applied to the
seasonal flu washing the hands and all
those normal things would also protect
you it would certainly you know and and
I I just I can't explain something about
the fact that this is a new thing right
it came from China which is scaring
people it's like some other mysterious
thing that came you know like the h1n1
and other kind of ants are is in fact
h1n1 was 1920 1921 swine flu swine flu
yeah exactly so this is a this is
actually a mystery why people are so
worked up about this and I think it has
to do with the fact that it is new it's
getting a lot of attention we don't know
quite what didn't have about it have we
been able to track a virus with this
level of daily updates before today
before this level of Internet and social
media access well it's not really you
know there's a lot to and by the way
there's a lot that we don't know about
all the updates it's crazy and part of
it is that we just don't know a lot of
key information what's the incubation
period
yeah so we're telling people it's 2 to
14 days probably 3 to 4 weeks actually
for some people so um you keep carrying
this from area and transmit it while
you're carrying yes even though you
don't have symptoms exactly oh my god so
asymptomatic transmission it's readable
it's possible okay I'm sorry you know
what I'm gonna calm down
don't panic
yeah so well under what conditions does
anyone ever tell you don't panic right
yeah right no never walks into a room
and says ladies and gentlemen the
building is not on fire don't panic yeah
yeah it's like calm down yeah so yeah no
this is this is really a problem now I
just want to clarify something you
obviously spread more virus when you're
coughing and sneezing correct but still
when you're asymptomatic you're still
able to transmit it and that's something
that people should be aware of okay so
now again compare it to a normal season
Alou where all these same precautions
would prevent that but we're not
undergoing those same precautions for
the seasonal flu correct this is
actually a keystone kops level of
incompetence in the federal government
that there is a delay you know the thing
is when did we get started because it
does take at least a year to year and a
half to make a vaccine because you have
to figure out the right combination and
understand the DNA the virus you have to
make it you have to do animal trials you
have to then do expanded human trials
and you have to manufacture and
distribute it
however okay we got overhead yeah adds
up yeah it does and if you add to that
two or three months of inexplicable
delays and screw-ups if you [ __ ] use
them on this podcast by the federal
government you have a really really bad
situation you just worry whether you can
say the word screw up I did and you know
we got to take them to the hood I had to
control myself but okay yeah so um
yeah and III just we've never seen the
CDC this dysfunctional so now with that
in mind let's just talk about four
because there is you know mixed
messaging happening at the highest
levels of government what can we do
knowing that at a vaccine yes like a
year away yeah what can we do without as
Neal told me without panicking well what
we can do is first of all we could
actually use the old tried-and-true
contact your representatives and your
you know people in Congress and tell
them we want everything accelerated we
want enough money appropriated to and to
deal with this we want staff rehired the
CDC stop you from getting the disease no
no no it's fine - I mean yeah though
after he just told us a story about how
dysfunctional it was right so that's
what well no I meant what can we do to
not get to disease what I was like in
this answer as well basically the thing
is while we're waiting for the vaccine
we're doing the things that Neal
mentioned before were a lot of frequent
obsessive hand-washing we're using hand
sanitizers if you can't even get it now
which you can for about $500 in a little
for a little bottle on yes all that yeah
yeah oh you noticed yes yes yes so no
that's really unfortunate but you take
care of yourself you make sure that if
you're sick if you got respiratory
symptoms please don't go in public stay
home we want businesses to really gear
up including this one for example to be
able to work remotely as much as
possible if things really go to hell and
we have lots of spread fortunately
remote working is is more real than ever
absolutely the world absolutely right
for more people not everyone okay you
can't flip hamburgers remotely but for a
lot of other jobs you can you can't
exactly right and so people should be
right now assessing their abilities to
do that and making sure their staff know
what to do and that they've got all the
equipment I need to do this kind of
remote working and teleconferencing and
so on
and you notice until when until I don't
know when actually I'm sorry to say
because we don't know how long it's
going to last
the director the National Center for
disaster preparedness and I say what how
long do we do this
when is the asteroid hitting us it's
gonna say that's a snappy comeback but
it's is there a point where this isn't
it not an unrealistic scenario let me
imagine yeah that everyone does get the
message you don't go out if you have a
little respiratory thing if you're
sneezy you stay in you wash your hands
all the time you clean surfaces is it
possible that the co vid will just
lightly wash over the country and then
exit and then we come out with a minimal
damage is that possible it's not out of
the question
and given the fact this is the whole
problem of these quote unquote novel or
new viruses that we weed so much we
don't know about their behavior what
might happen you could postulate almost
any trajectory scenario yeah and you
know it's possible that'll say Dawei I
don't know why it would particularly
could just become endemic it could be
coming slowly just always passing around
right and it could become seasonal like
a regular seasonal flu in which case
we'd incorporate the new vaccine for
this into the regular you know flu
vaccines you get every day so then then
it becomes not really an issue and the
second thing is that we might actually
develop an antiviral medication that's
specific for this and that would be good
too but right now we don't really have
those things so we're trying to really
do all the containment we possibly can
would you say that the public has been
overreacting based on everything you've
seen well the it's empty shelves in the
grocery store yeah well that's you know
this panic buying stuff is not a good
idea plus the general hope is that
people will get ready for disasters
anyway they'll have a certain amount of
food and water at all times in case some
other kind of thing happens and and of
course that that hasn't really happened
no there's been no penetration of that
message particularly either but maybe
we'll this will kind of stimulate people
to do that
but we don't want to go crazy but I'll
tell you there's a couple key things
that people
need to be reminded about when they're
stocking up in case they have to be self
quarantine one is if you have a pet
what's gonna happen you're gonna be able
to walk the dog you know have you have
cat litter do you have all the stuff you
need for the pet secondly your baby baby
if it's if you have a very young baby
who's being breastfed that's fine an
older child who's on either formula or
needs other food or baby food make sure
you have that make sure you have diapers
and all that and all that stuff and wise
but the third thing which is maybe most
important is that if you have a chronic
illness and you're dependent on daily
meds too for life you know like you have
diabetes or serious heart disease make
sure that you have enough stock of those
medications to see you through whatever
period of quarantine that we're getting
ready for that's the thing where the
supply chain by the way could be most
problematic because if we can't get this
stuff and you can't go to the drug store
transportation grid right there
everything everything is problematic
about I'd rather have you have it in
your medicine chest in on a shelf
someplace so that you have it available
promise we'll the insurance companies
was about to get this ahead of time
right and what about all the uninsured
people in general by the way even
getting a test is a problem and another
12 12 million undocumented people who
are really fearful legitimately so I've
even gone to a doctor a hospital because
they might get deported in that
afternoon so we have all sorts of social
economic problems that really keep us
from being optimally prepared that said
the majority of people need to do the
kind of things we're just talking about
why don't we do what we did when I was a
kid where when we were kids we r the
same age where you know someone has the
mumps everyone brings the kids in to get
the mumps and then we're all immunized
by our own chickenpox or the chickenpox
maybe not the moms come to my party at
my house yeah there's some people who
had only mild symptoms and presumably
when those things go away they have an
immunity well that's was the presumption
oh but here's the problem as this virus
mutates you may have been
you know resistant to getting it again
today but if it mutates enough so it
doesn't really evoke the same immune
response in your body so your antibodies
were ready for what it used to look like
yeah if it's yesterday and not what it
looks like tomorrow so it does like a
Tom Cruise Mission Impossible reveal it
was me
the coronavirus all along I fooled you
immune system right well okay so yeah so
the worst case is it's it's endemic a
seasonal you get it but you guys figure
out a vaccine and we just liberal bar
medic viral and we just live with it
yeah but when we come back we're finally
gonna get to questions that we've
solicited from our fan base on disaster
preparedness and the carbon nitrogen
virus to Startalk returns
we're back Startalk cosmic queries which
side of it says that there we go cosmic
queries it's dark doc a special edition
yes we're talking about disaster
preparedness and viruses in particular
the covert 19 virus I've got dr. Irwin
redlener he's actually an old friend
Chuck I don't if you do that I did not
he goes way back I know you know a
friend we had in common by the name of
Carl Sagan oh wow yeah yeah he worked
with Carl on some humanitarian projects
is that right oh yeah yeah detectives on
the board of the Children's Health Fund
my foundation yeah excellent excellent
so good to hear that and you've been
he's just a good guy the whole time yes
we have to chauffeur them so Chuck let's
get some questions out here from a
patreon members start with them go for
it this is Morgan Dylan from patreon of
course do we really need to be so
worried about this virus that's killing
less people than the common flu it seems
it's just hype by the media so two
things kind of baked into that yes how
much is clickbait because if I saw a
news story that said outbreak in a new
place I'm clicking on it okay so how
much of it is just yeah no no I'm gonna
call a dishonest reporting but just
sensationalist reporting yeah sort of
over the top you know it's it's really
it's gotten so muddled now in terms of
this that it's really it's hard to know
I I would say that we need to be
cautious we need to make sure that the
systems are being developed to allow us
to prevent and treat this thing and when
there's serious outbreaks we need to pay
attention because we actually don't want
to get this even though the fatality
rate may not be you know great it is a
new virus that we can't really treat and
so you you want to do what what is
appropriate without without panicking as
we're talking about before so you want
to stock up in case somebody is you got
to be quarantined and by the way that's
no joke if you're told to quarantine
there's actually police authority right
to enforce that so you want to be able
to do that comfortably but you you know
you we're gonna take
this it's sort of everyday every one day
at a time here but the fact is that
paying attention this is not
inappropriate going over the top and
panicking is not appropriate
how about domestic travel so domestic
travel I came back from Denver a few
days ago with my wife and one of my
granddaughter's and one row ahead of me
on the other side of the aisle was two
guys who were wearing face masks which
got my attention and one of them starts
coughing like crazy and sneezing lifts
up his facemask to blow his nose blows
of those in a tissue puts it in the seat
pocket in front of him by the way I I
get up and I go to the purser did you
eject him from the emergency exit excuse
me sir but these guys you know and he
said listen there's nothing we can do
about it I said are they screened the
guys are walking on the airplane with
face masks so we check their temperature
do we get it you know were they just
coming back from Wuhan and now going
from for some reason from Denver to New
York with us so we can't ask them we
don't know anything blah blah blah okay
okay all right next question okay here
we go
this is a David hem SAFF and he says I
don't expect the following to be read on
the upcoming show it's too long and
there's no question it and I just wanted
to say David you're right what can we
say this is Matt hare field who says
according to dr. redlener what is the
most important aspect of disaster
preparedness when it comes to virus
outbreaks and what is the u.s. currently
the best or worst at affecting well good
questions and so first of all let's just
start with this in general it is always
a good idea to be attentive to
appropriate sanitation santa fe sanitary
habits you know hand-washing frequently
cleaning off surfaces on places like
airplane trays and things like that
now are there some surfaces where last
longer than is yes if it's a very porous
surface less so than on a hard surface
but that's variable whatever it is you
get on an airplane I would use some sort
of Clorox infused wipe and I clean off
the trays and clean off the TV screen I
clean off the armor these are typically
touch screens right yeah yeah you don't
want to try to just put your hand in the
pocket very unfortunate surprised but
yeah that wouldn't put your hand there
the quick thing we're of a generation
where the gentleman always had a cloth
handkerchief in their pocket and would
offer it to other people
ill to blow their nose isn't that
completely
nasty yeah I would try not to do that
yeah you know I wouldn't do that yeah
but so the second part of the tummy tuck
again what he said what are we best at
doing in terms of this country so what
what should we do and it trying to have
drive through South Korea sorry South
Korea they've drive through testing yes
and how about us Wow
so let's start with what we're not very
good at it seems and I was I'm surprised
by this myself which were not very good
apparently at developing the
technologies to start paying attention
early enough we completely missed the
boat on this I'm surprised because it's
in some ways transcends whoever's in
political power at the White House this
is this is something that through all
administration's we depended upon really
world-class experts in the CDC and NIH
and so on certain things at all times
transcend politics probably most things
should but anyway
so here we are at a time that we were
really we're hoping for weigh weight
especially professionals in my field
public health in general we expected
much much more from the NIH in the CDC
and that those those parts of the
permanent competence or is that low
budget I
we're both we I don't think it's
incompetent certainly not at the high
levels
but we may have kind of strangled the
ability for the organization's to
functions they usually do by by you know
by dropping staff or whatever but but
what do we do best then give me some
hope here you know I was last time I'm
inviting you all right the show itself
as a source of hope is it oh man
guess what do we do best in terms of
this this guy real thing yeah I guess
we're pretty good at communications
until we get to be over the top which is
where we're on the verge of right now
mm-hmm
on the other hand we don't know where
where the top is yeah we don't know that
we're not where the numbers the case is
stabilized or they drop what is the top
do you will you know the time when
you're there yeah well the top is when
we start seeing spread and we start
seeing a serious persistent diminishing
of the number of cases right okay all
right so this is anthony taylor and he
says and i read this for a specific
reason that i'll attach to the end how
big or small is a virus compared to an
atom or a molecule with that the reason
why i asked this question what is the
efficacy of wearing a mask when it comes
to staving off the transmission of the
virus
whether you're transmitting it or
receiving it right so viruses are very
very tiny okay and they are much smaller
than say bacteria okay Neil could
probably tell you more about the exhibit
here yeah in the whole of the universe
yeah that has a physical model of a of a
red blood cell yeah and then on the next
scale you see the size of a virus which
is like it's minuscule correct correct
gotcha so masks this has been of course
controversial and it's been a rush on
mass you can't even buy one now but
there's two basic kind of mass mass one
is called the surgical mask it is more
porous than the other mask which is
what's called a respirator mask or an
n95 and 95s are worn by people that are
dealing with a lot of high risk
patience they have to be changed every
four to six hours actually and they are
they will stop a much more particle
getting through but they're also very
hard to breathe through you you you
would have a lot of trouble wearing one
of those all just to be clear an actual
virus can fit through any mask yeah
we're talking about a virus that's part
of a particle right a vapour particle
would have to attest ops the water
droplet and with the virus in it right
okay but but Neil's point is very
important because it was if the virus
became really air analyzed on its own it
could get through any mess any mask
right so but so you're kind of going
back to the hygienic techniques that you
talked about right for or making sure
for being preventative taking
preventative measures is that we're
still getting right back to that even
with the masks and all that he only
comes down to the obsessive hand-washing
and you know personal space and don't
shake hands don't shake that's that's
exactly right yeah but you know you see
people that's right black people never
used to get sick because we all did the
fist by and oh and Rojo that's right
right yeah that's why he's a known
social commentator probably go deeper
here but I want to say something about
go ahead man please go ahead it is
useless to walk around the street in a
mask
unless you have yourself respiratory
symptoms so in other words and then you
not to prevent you from getting it is to
prevent all the people getting it from
you exactly right that's that's it
that's an important point so don't wear
a mask walking around the streets of New
York or anywhere else and don't even
bother trying to deal with a not n95
mask and then if you have on a mask and
you want to sneeze don't remove the mask
[Laughter]
an MD
[Music]
so I'll give you some hope before we
wrap this up yeah so the hope is that
we've now gotten our act together I
think the message is out and we need to
you know pay attention to what's
developing we can hope that in fact it
will level out and we won't have the
major global problem and it'll end up
having a fatality rate as low or lower
than the seasonal flu it'll become part
of the regular flu vaccines that we get
every year and that will go about our
business but there is definitely hope
it's just that it's a new thing and
people are you know obviously distressed
about it and it's a big news story but
you know focus on the primaries I think
that's better
so to summarize some of what you said
but put an extra little twist on it
there was a day when we would elect
politicians who were our leaders and if
there was some kind of outbreak or some
kind of a disaster
you would sad what my leader says and I
will do what the leader tells me but
we're at a time now where trust of
politicians is not what it used to be
and so but we do have access to
institutions and expertise through the
internet and so the politician no longer
needs to be the conduit between us and
the scientific results and by the way a
good leader a good political leader can
find that balance between complacency
and panic and say truth and speak about
with transparency about what we know
here's what we know we don't think you
should panic here's what we need to know
and we're looking for it but in the
meantime do what's precautionary what's
appropriate and and but you know some
leaders have do that naturally and we
can tell that and we elect them all
right I think we got to end it there
yeah
Herrmann thanks for coming I'm sure in
years no no no yeah no we'll find
another excuse to get you back on this
show sure maybe for an update in a few
months Sheriff just to see any time if
we if it gets worse Wilmont more of you
but so will everyone else and if it gets
worse we'll do it via Skype yeah just
don't come over to my house at all all
right dr. Erwin ladder
the director of the National Center for
disaster preparedness Columbia
University you also with the medical
school is that correct yeah there's a
double title there yeah excellent and
Chuck always good to have you here
always the plasma fist-bumped at no
shaking hands all right no covert 19
there yeah you've been watching possibly
you're listening to Startalk cosmic
queries disaster preparedness edition on
Neil deGrasse Tyson as always giving you